Hello, Internet.
Welcome to Film Theory.
The show that promises to let you sit and
watch public domain cartoons for as long as
you want, provided you stab that subscribe
button right in the eye.
Now, I'm not a man with a whole lot of free
time.
Between launching new channels (subscribe
to Style Theory, by the way), writing and
rewriting FNAF timelines, being a father and,
you know, just trying to have an actual life,
things can get pretty darn busy.
But in what little free time I've had lately,
I've been scrolling through the TikToks to
see what's hip with the kiddos, and what I've
seen
has been nothing but pages and pages of Pedro
Pascal fan cams.
Do not make fan cams of school staff
Oh, you can't stop me, Pedro.
I can and I will.
But once I scrolled past those, I was inundated
by something far less esthetic and much more scary.
A terrifying new horror movie called Skinamarink,
Everything I saw heralded this thing as the
scariest movie EVAR
And based on the trailer alone, I was hooked.
Ladies and gentlemen, we have reached peak
analog horror.
So intrigued and a little bit scared.
I did what any normal person would do.
I sat down at 9 a.m. on a Wednesday morning
with two of my employees to watch through
this puppy.
And boy, was it controversial.
One of them rated it an eight.
The other rated it a zero and said it didn't
even deserve to be called a movie.
And honestly, I can't really blame him for
his opinion.
5 minutes in and it's immediately clear why
this thing is going to be a divisive movie.
It's about 100 minutes of staring at dark
walls and grainy hallways while people whisper
in the background.
It is not for everyone.
As for my opinion, I can tell you that it
was probably the most active movie watching
experience that I've ever had, with my eyes
constantly scanning the frame, questioning
whether what I was seeing was a shadow monster
or just artifacting on the camera.
I wasn't just passively watching a movie.
I was having to solve each and every frame,
trying to understand what exactly I was looking at.
TL;DR It worked for me.
I really enjoyed it.
But not only is Skinamarink a visually challenging
movie, it also is a narratively challenging one.
The story, as it's presented to us, is about
two young children, Kaylee and Kevin, who
wake up in the middle of the night to find
that their parents have disappeared, along
with all the house's doors and windows.
And so the kids in the movie respond like
any normal child would do in this sort of situation.
They park themselves right in front of that
TV and start binge watching some old school
copyright neutral cartoons.
Pretty soon, though, things get worse as they
begin to realize that they're not alone inside
the house as a formless demon who makes the
kids do horrific things like
Walk up the stairs and
Walk up the stairs again.
He is a very cardiovascular ghost.
Oh, yeah.
Also put a knife in your eye.
We don't actually see anything, but the sudden
switch to implied violence is just incredibly jarring.
Bit by bit, things get progressively worse
for our young duo.
Toys begin sticking to the ceiling.
Night lights get unplugged.
The toilets disappear.
Man, this demon is ruthless.
The eye thing, yeah, that was brutal.
But making them poop in buckets?
That’s just cruel.
Eventually, Kaylee disappears, leaving the
four year old Kevin alone in a house that
has literally and figuratively turned upside
down.
As the movie ends, we see this image stating
572 days, which is super random, because up
to this point, there really hasn't been any
clear focus on the passage of time.
And then you have this brutally long pull
out shot that lasts almost two consecutive
minutes, just really milking it for that watch
time, aren't they?
On an unrelated note, did I mention the director
for this thing got his start on YouTube?
I See you.
I know what you're doing.
I know your secrets.
There's a bit more screaming and whispering
and blood before the movie ultimately ends,
with a blurry figure fading into frame, telling
Kevin to.
And that's about it.
Clear as crystal, right?
Well, yeah, actually, kinda.
On the surface, it seems like just another
spooky ghost movie.
But looking at it that way, actually leaves
a lot of unanswered questions: What was the monster?
Why did everything disappear?
Where did the parents go?
What is the significance of 572 days?
And what does that ending actually mean?
In short, this movie is an open invite for
theorists to solve.
And you know what?
I think I cracked it.
What seems like a simple ghost story is actually
a tragedy.
A terribly sad story about loss, grief and
family trauma.
All told from the perspective of a four year
old child.
Everything we see in the film feels like a
paranormal situation, right?
We hear voices.
We see things stuck to the ceiling.
We have doors disappearing, and we have this
constant grain and distortion.
What could cause all of this, if not a demon?
Well, let's just start from the very beginning.
The movie kicks off with a seemingly random
event where Kevin falls down some stairs.
In the middle of the night, we see a series
of clips of Kevin stealing blankets from his
closet, sitting up on top of the stairs.
And then we get an upside down shot of the
bottom of the stairs after hearing a loud thud.
This is then followed up by his dad on the
phone.
It seems pretty cut and dry.
Kevin falls down some stairs and hits his
head.
There's just one problem with that.
This incident is never mentioned again.
It is completely arbitrary for everything
that comes afterwards.
It goes nowhere and nothing comes of it.
Why would the director be showing us this
then?
Why is it the first event of the movie?
Well, I suspect it's because this is the real
incident that incites everything we see happen afterward.
The fall sends Kevin into a coma, and everything
we see from that point onward in the movie
are the real world events being filtered and
processed through his unconscious condition.
Now, let me immediately say that I know how
lame coma theories are.
You can make anything fit into a coma or dream
theory because there's no logic in these things.
Anything can be bent to be a piece of evidence.
There is a reason that across the 1,012 theories
that I've written across the last decade,
only one of them has claimed that everything
was a dream.
That's because I only pull them out when I
think that that's the author's true intent.
And with Skinamarink, I am convinced that
this is the right interpretation.
Obviously, we just talked about the inciting
incident of a head injury, but there is so,
so much more here.
Across the entirety of the movie there are
three random details of this supposed haunting
that stood out to me as unusual: the missing
toilets, the request to stick a knife in Kevin's
eye, and the marker of 572 days.
So let's just go back and tackle these one
at a time.
First, let's just take a look at the basic
concept of the film itself.
While the idea of doors and windows disappearing
from a house makes for a creepy paranormal
setup, what doesn't fit quite as well as the
disappearance of the toilets.
The lack of doors and windows I totally get.
You're trapped inside of a situation that
you can't escape from.
You're at the mercy of the demon.
But the toilets?
I mean, why would a paranormal entity do that?
It's either a big troll or this isn't actually
a ghost that we're dealing with.
So let's just assume that everything after
Kevin falls down the stairs and hits his head
takes place in a hospital.
Well, if that's truly the case, then the disappearing
toilets would be the reality of his current situation.
He's no longer physically going to the bathroom
and toilets anymore, depending on the policy
of the hospital he's in, he's likely using
a bedpan, diapers or a rectal catheter to
excrete his waste.
This would also explain the disappearing doors
and windows that form the core of this movie's plot.
On one hand, it's symbolic of Kevin now being
trapped inside his own mind with no escape.
That's why near the end of the movie, when
he asks to watch something happy, we see visions
of a door.
It's a moment or a chance of escape, but the
disappearing doors and windows could also
literally be the hospital room around him,
a claustrophobic space that's blocked off
by curtains.
In fact, look closer at your typical hospital
room.
And what do you see in each one?
A TV sitting in front of the patient, playing
all day, every day.
And what do we see in Skinamarink?
A TV as a constant presence throughout everything
in the film.
So much of this movie is spent sitting in
front of a TV, specifically public domain
cartoons.
It's got to mean something, right?
It does.
These cartoons are the entire plot of the
movie.
If you take a closer look at the cartoons
that play and when they play, they seem to
be telling us the real story of what's happening
in the movie.
One of the first cartoons we see after Kevin's
accident is this, a baby bird being shot out
of the sky and appearing dead?
This cartoon is the song of the Birds from
1935.
Except there's a twist here if you watch beyond
what they show in Skinamarink.
When the birds go to bury the baby's body,
he wakes up and everyone celebrates.
This cartoon, I suspect, is representative
of Kevin's injury.
He's the baby bird who was knocked unconscious.
This clip even plays after the kids ask the
question.
It's because Mom thinks that her baby bird
is dead or maybe just close to death.
The second major cartoon we see is the Cobweb
Hotel from 1936, where two newlywed flies
watch helplessly as a young fly is trapped
inside a monstrous spider's bed of webs.
They then have to fight to escape from the
spider.
Now, this could very easily be symbolic of
Kevin and Kaylee fighting against the monster
that has them trapped inside the house.
But it could also be Kevin's parents forced
to watch their son trapped inside of a hospital
bed, unable to escape.
Considering that the two newly wed flies are
adults, I suspect it's the second explanation.
The third major cartoon reference we get is
to 1931's Bimbo's initiation.
This one we don't actually see, but I was
able to recognize the audio from research
we did years ago when we did our Bendy and
the Ink Machine episode about rubber hose animation.
In this one, Bimbo falls down a sewer only
to be locked in a prison of inescapable false
doors, all while the world turns upside down
around him.
Ha. A character falls down, winds up trapped in
a place without doors and everything turns
upside down.
Why even have a movie Skinamarink?
You told us everything we needed to know,
right there.
And in the final cartoon, 1939’s Prest-O
Change-O.
We see this clip of a dog that's being shot
in the eye.
Again, sound familiar?
The cartoons are telling the story of Kevin's
life.
And why are they always on?
Why are they always playing?
Because he's sitting in a hospital room, stuck
in front of a TV.
But With all that said, let's look a bit closer
at the eye bit.
It's one of the very few moments of implied
violence in the movie so obviously it's going
to stand out as important.
But again, why?
Why this of all things?
just to shock us?
Again, I don't think so.
Let's take a look back at what caused Kevin
to fall down the stairs in the first place.
Hayley says he was sleepwalking.
Sleepwalking, hallucinations, eye pain.
it doesn't take Derek Shepherd to know what's
going on with this one.
Kevin has a brain tumor.
And, yeah, that was a Gray's Anatomy reference
for any of you under the age of 45.
I suspect Kevin was suffering from a tumor
on the frontal lobe of his brain, thereby
causing him to sleepwalk, hallucinate and
ultimately fall down the stairs.
In fact, brain tumors are the most common
form of solid tumor inside of children, affecting
about 5,000 in the U.S. every year.
What I suspect happened here was that the
brain tumor caused his sleepwalking and subsequent fall.
And while the fall itself might have resulted
in a minor injury, considering what we hear
from Dad's phone call, the subsequent hospital
visit, or the damage that the fall caused
made the tumor issue worse.
With kevin ultimately winding up in a coma
shortly thereafter.
So what does all of that have to do with knives
and eyes?
Well, I don't think that it was just any knife
we're talking about here.
I think what's going on is a surgical procedure.
One way to remove tumors from the frontal
lobe of the brain is to perform a procedure
known as a supraorbital keyhole craniotomy,
a type of brain surgery where they go in through,
you guessed it, the eye.
It's minimally invasive and it's an easier
way to reach the frontal lobe to remove the
tumor, which is why Kevin feels like he's
being stabbed in the eye with a knife.
This would also explain another weird detail
that we see towards the end of the film.
At the top of the movie, we get a montage
of various family photos hanging on the wall.
At the end, we get a similar montage, but
this time everyone is missing their head or
the faces have been weirdly distorted.
This would be the result of a condition known
as prosopagnosia, also known as face blindness,
where you cannot recognize people's faces.
It's a symptom that often appears in patients
with brain tumors.
This leads us then to the ending of the film
where we see blood being sprayed on the floor
over and over, all while we hear screaming
in the background and the repeating music
from the Prest-O Change-O cartoon, the one
where the dog gets shot in the eye.
If you turn on the closed captions, the first
round of screaming we hear is captioned as
“child crying”.
Thank you closed caption people (*o*) for
not naming him the crying child.
I just can't rewrite the damn FNAF timeline
again.
The next round of screaming though, is credited
as “older child cries”.
This scene, I suspect, is Kevin being operated
on over and over, over a prolonged period.
That's why the blood spills on the carpet
repeatedly, why the music is pulled from the
cartoon that references his eye pain and why
the subtitles differentiate child and older child.
It is two years of Kevin in a coma undergoing
procedures like this as doctors try and repeatedly
fail at removing the tumor that's endangering
his life.
How do I know it's been two years?
the 572 days marker that we see in the film's
final act.
At no point in the movie is there ever any
sort of emphasis on the passage of time.
And yet, for some reason, the film decides
to call out this little fact as important.
I suspect that this is how long Kevin's in
a coma before he finally passes on.
They're calling out the final day of his life,
and he's being ushered into the afterlife
by his mother.
You see, at the end of the surgery sequence,
Kevin cries out for his mommy.
He's looking to her for help, but she doesn't
come.
It's only in the final shot of the movie that
she arrives.
This blurry, nightmare fueled, faceless homunculus
in the back.
Yeah, that right there is his mommy.
And she's telling him to go to sleep, to pass
on.
Kevin is being released from his pain and
the movie ends.
But why is his mom here now?
Well, to understand that, we have to zoom
out.
You see, this whole time I've been trying
to prove to you that Kevin's in a coma.
And I feel real good about that conclusion
and the evidence that we've presented so far.
But in the process, I've been having to ignore
what's happening around Kevin, specifically
around his parents.
This whole movies premise is that Kaylee and
Kevin's dad disappears one night.
Notice that I see dad specifically and not
parents.
That's actually in the official movie's description.
So why is Dad gone?
And where is Mom?
Well, we hear mentions of Mom very sparingly.
Early on we hear the question
shortly afterward.
We spend some quality time with mom in one
of the most disturbing scenes of the movie.
Kaylee is brought up to her parents room by
the mysterious voice, her dad is sitting hunched
on the bed. Kaylee looks away for a moment
and suddenly her dad is gone, replaced with
her mom.
After a half-hearted hey-we're-getting-a-divorce-kiddo
style talk.
We hear a very clear snapping sound.
This paired with the repeated imagery we see
of dolls hanging from the ceiling, leads me
to believe that their mother unfortunately
took her own life, she was so distraught over
Kevin's condition that she cries repeatedly,
the family gets a divorce and then she ultimately
ends it all this works with why we hear Kaylee
asking about the crying and why at a later
point, when asked about Mom, she says
That's also why Mom's at the end of the movie,
helping to ease Kevin into the afterlife.
It's because she's there too.
She's also dead.
Okay, so we've established why we don't see
Mom, but then what explains Dad's disappearance?
Well, Kevin's dad just doesn't come to visit
anymore.
We know that Kevin's been in his hospital
bed for 572 days based on the text from the
end of the movie.
572 days in a coma, almost two years.
Dad just can't do it anymore.
He disappears.
There's only one person left who wants to
come and see Kevin, who will sit with him
and watch cartoons with him on the hospital
TV who still talks to him, Kaylee.
But even she eventually succumbs to the monster.
Even she gives up to the hopeless darkness
that Kevin won't wake up.
Her mouth was stolen.
She disappears, too, just like everyone else.
One of the final shots of the movie is the
return to the stair banister upside down the
way Kevin saw it after his fall.
This provides our story a complete bookend.
We return back to where everything began.
The house at this point has figuratively and
literally been turned upside down and now
appears to Kevin in the way that he saw it
after his tumble.
Skinamarink is a tragic tale of a family broken
apart, of a loving father, mother and sister,
forced to confront an unforgiving and unending
medical condition.
And the little boy who's trapped in a hospital
bed with no way out trying to understand it
all through the grainy dark filter of his
unconscious state.
Even the name Skinamarink tells us exactly
what this movie's about.
It's the name of a children's nursery rhyme
all about love.
That is the central theme of the film: Love.
And that's also the true horror of this film,
that there are just some things that love
can't overcome, some things that are so dark,
so ceaseless, that they swallow all that love away.
Oof, this film really hits so much harder
than I expected a TikTok hyped arthouse horror
film to do.
So if you have kids, give them a hug.
If you are a kid, go give your parents a hug.
We got to counteract the horribly sad with
something wholesome.
But hey!
If you ever find yourself trapped in a dream
house with disappearing doors and windows,
you're probably going to want some food delivered
to you.
Well, with the sponsor of today's video, Hello
Fresh
that dream can become a reality.
Hello Fresh has 40 weekly recipes for you to
choose from.
So we always get something new and exciting.
And if you're on a low calorie carb smart
or veggie focused diet or just a really picky
eater, not only are there plenty of options
for you, you can also customize your meals.
Switching out proteins and sides, or even
adding proteins to a veggie dish.
Steph and I have a lot going on, so getting
delicious food delivered directly to our doorstep
so we can skip a trip to the grocery store.
It is a game changer.
It lets us spend more time focused on decoding
the stories of strange indie horror movies
and less time deciding on what we want for
dinner.
Hello Fresh also helps us cut back on takeout
and delivery, the cost of which can add up
real fast.
I mean, why go out to get restaurant quality
food when delicious food can just show up
at your doorstep and you get the satisfaction
of making it fresh for yourself?
One of the meals we got recently were these
delicious Monterey Jack burgers with potato
wedges, and it felt so great getting hands
on cooking these things.
Hello Fresh sends pre-portioned ingredients
and easy to follow recipes that let us make
this incredible hand cooked dinner without
having to think about meal planning or meal prep.
And that is awesome.
Even better, all the ingredients in this meal
were super fresh with less than seven days
between these things being on a farm to getting
on our doorstep.
If you want to try your hand at cooking your
own meals with a ton of different options,
go to HelloFresh.com and use the code FILMTHEORY65
for 65% off plus free shipping. Once again
that's HelloFresh.com with the code FILMTHEORY65
or you can just click the link down to the
description if you don't want to type all
that out.
That is 65% off and free shipping.
Not too shabby.
Thanks again to Hello Fresh for sponsoring
today's video.
And as always, remember, it's all just a theory.
A FILM THEORY!
aaaaaaaaand cut.